are really like a speed round we're very
excited for this first panel and without
further ado I'm gonna let them take the
stage good morning everyone it is my
honor to introduce such a great panel
today which includes a former Navy SEAL
sorry had to say that a Pittsburgh
Steeler a serial entrepreneur what was
supposed to be the Queen attack but she
had a family emergency and someone
working to solve a very big
transportation issue in the region our
moderator today Don Morrison he's at the
end there he's the serial entrepreneur
who's been involved in the growth of
several businesses most notably American
Eagle Outfitters there he grew the
company as president CEO from 1 to 165
stores
he's currently chairman of deal flow for
blue treant allied angels and chairman
of the Linden Point Development
Corporation LDC Don's also entrepreneur
in residence at the University of
Pittsburgh's innovation Institute and
he's a coach and a mentor to a whole
bunch of startups in the region curry
Crookston you raise your hand curry
right here is head of innovation
management at KU best row a company
which is doing some very interesting and
innovative things these days he's the
next at the ex-navy seal a grad of the
u.s. Naval Academy with an MBA from
Virginia he's been busy implementing
business model innovation otherwise
known as BMI creating and growing text
based businesses as an entrepreneur and
as part of a larger organization next we
have jeff mcdaniel jeff served in the
Navy as a Surface Warfare Officer and
he's an attorney one badass combination
if you ask me he's now executive in
residence at innovation works working
with the management teams have start up
clean
gee and manufacturing tech companies
jeffrey provides mentoring and network
access to the portfolio companies that
innovation marks and serves as an
observer on the board of directors
it's definitely someone I would want to
my team Carly we hope Carly she's the
only female here now is the staff lead
for an initiative to develop a regional
transportation innovation and investment
strategy at the Allegheny Conference for
community development that's a very big
deal as many of you know right now she's
working with the very dynamic Anna
sofyan here at Carnegie Mellon and other
local partners on assessing the energy
startup ecosystem in our region today
the goal is to identify a strategy for
further investment and private
partnership support that leaves that I
would have left two people one of whom
was Audrey I was going to say both of
them graduated from Ohio State
University but only one played football
Hey
she is not here due to a family
emergency we will really miss her but
that leaves Will Allen who co manages
the day-to-day operations and investment
and acquisition strategy for nascent
Group Holdings he completed a program to
the NFL at Harvard Business School and
he interned with congressman Bobby Rush
on the energy and Power subcommittee and
as you all know will played in the NFL
for 12 seasons most recently for the
Pittsburgh Steelers he was member the
Ohio State 2002 national championship
team and was named a consensus
all-american all that is super
impressive but so is this he serves on
the advisory committee for be a middle
school mentor through the United Way
he's on numerous boards through town and
he established the Will Allen Foundation
which provides tools and resources to
educate influence and empower people in
his surrounding community so I now turn
this over to Don in this very impressive
panel enjoy Thank You Tracy
and thank you for being on the panel I'm
honored to be up here with such
distinguished panelists this
has a great manufacturing legacy in
steel and aluminum and glass in more
recent years Pittsburghers developed
reputation for EDS and meds but also for
artificial intelligence robotics
autonomous Beal vehicles in computer
technology yet many people when it comes
to conversations about energy Pittsburgh
is not top of mind so why do you think
Pittsburgh should be included in the
energy conversation I think that
Pittsburgh is included in the energy
conversation and we have a strong
presence with that I mean oil and gas is
strong clean energy is a very strong
here within the state the Allegheny
County leads leads every County and
clean energy jobs and I don't I don't
know if that's promoted or celebrated
enough but that's you know that's your
solar that's your wind that's your
advanced HVAC manufacturing and that
needs to be discussed more and I don't
think it needs to be competitive outside
of the traditional oil and gas industry
that's that's that that's the present so
you know Pittsburgh and the region you
know is very strong as it relates to
energy and the investments and you know
where we're going I mean that industry
the clean energy industry has grown six
percent every year over the last five
years so it's it's really exciting where
we can go I just think it needs to be
celebrated and we need more advocates
for that right I think we whether you've
been a Pittsburgher or all your life or
coming one and only been here for a few
days or years there's this Pittsburgh
humbleness
we rarely toot our own horn and I
believe that we have for a long time
been among cities that should have the
right to claim the title of energy
capital of the world
we have been known for that before at
least twice in the last 200 some odd
years and I think we're on the verge of
becoming known for that breadth of
energy expertise again if a few more of
us tune our own horn and on that note
about the humbleness we really do have a
unique concentration of energy research
happening here it's not just you know
we're all aware probably of one little
slice of that pie but the fact that we
have two federal research labs that
bring a billion dollars you know
annually into the region that we've got
multiple universities multiple
engineering programs multiple other
really energy related research
activities programs work force all these
things add up together to have a lot
more concentration here that has a
multiplying effect and so for that alone
if we can just take a look at that and
really think about how we promote that
out and how we coordinate it we
absolutely should be part of the energy
conversation so Currier we just under
market it from an energy perspective I
think there's a the other part of the
equation also has is that there's also
large users so think about for example
cadastro are conic you know just in
North America we use nine figures in
electricity and so if you think about
the side of the research and development
the other part of that equation is that
people to actually use the energy and so
there's a lot of large players in the
region that are ideal customers for
those technologies that were developing
and we're actually not a slouch as a
state in terms of producing that energy
and electricity there were second in the
nation in terms of electricity
production we're second for natural gas
production or second for nuclear power
generation I mean these are out of 50
states Pennsylvania is already poised to
really be the center of a lot of the
energy production side so it is it's the
users it's the research it's the ideas
that are already developing here and
then sort of how you pull it all
together so does the Allegheny
conference have a marketing strategy
about energy or related to energy so the
Allegheny conference is a regional
economic development organization and
we have over the years done various
things to market sort of our energy
resources and assets but really what's
new now is focusing more on the
innovation side and on how we can do a
better job not just us but with a lot of
partners who are in the room and and
beyond to do a better job marketing the
energy startup assets that are here that
is sort of something that I think a lot
of us have talked about being a gap that
we've never really wrapped our arms
around and gotten a handle on one shared
messaging platform to promote jointly
I'm gonna be asking a few more questions
but I just wanted to point out anyone in
the audience has any questions you can
just submit it to the slide Oh calm up
on the screen and magically sent to my
laptop up here the word energy means
different things to different people
first thing that comes to some people's
mind is traditional fossil fuels
particularly the development natural gas
in the region to other people energy
means alternative energy electric call
cars battery technology wind and solar
what advantages does Pittsburgh have in
either of those two sectors such as of
resources and competitive advantages
with other regions
I think I'll take a stab at that
although I think one of the things that
the positions Pittsburgh to be
considered an energy capital the world
is that for the most part we take a
all-of-the-above approach to energy so
it's not necessarily as limited in scope
or in category and I think that the
innovation piece of that we're perhaps a
little bit more willing to apply new
technology to existing applications so
what was the was a question again
actually what advantages do we have in
either a traditional fossil fuel energy
sector or in the alternative clean tech
energy sector so I think one of the
advantages is just experience we've been
challenged by demand whether it was to
you know fire or fuel plants for a
couple centuries now so we've had to
figure out how to innovate whether it
was how to burn wood how to burn coal
other fossil fuels and utilize them and
I think that we also have then spun out
all of these other industries that have
also had a requirement of sorts so
whether it was materials expertise that
that we gained and then looking at
taking that experience and turning it
right back into applying it into maybe
new energy sources or technologies I
would I would say it's the
diversification that we have here it's
not necessarily you know one aspect of
energy called a traditional oil and gas
that were
hang on and if you look at the Gulf Gulf
Coast it's is all oil and gas and if a
major disaster happens what happens to
the production we we see what happened
you know without with a natural gas
pipeline recently we just shut off so
that that that disrupts the whole entire
industry I think we are in a safe
geographical location in western
Pennsylvania in the region to to
diversify to have natural gas production
and exploration but also to and have a
very robust innovation mindset you know
get a Carnegie Mellon here you get Pitt
you have so so much activity going on I
think well what we lack is that we're
not capturing it and streamlining it to
where it could be commercialized and
accelerated and I think once we once we
realized that aspect of it just you know
oil and gas it's very easy you do a
geological study you drill pump it out
you make money it is very simple
technology and innovation is a little
bit more complex than that and it takes
oh and it's a long wave and I think once
we figure that out you know who can stop
Pittsburgh who can stop the region at
that point it's it's it's hard to it's
hard to do that when with with such
diversification we as a region also have
really gotten out in front of some of
the workforce and talent pipeline issues
in order to be able to support all this
work we need to make sure we have enough
people who are trained interested
skilled you know wanting to work in
these spaces and that it that cuts
across both spaces so the alternative
energy sort of new technologies as well
as really maximizing the traditional
ones so for example in 2010 we started
we began what's now a national model for
shale nets which is a stackable
credential wing program hard for me to
say stackable credentialing program
basically they help more people be able
to do some of those natural gas
extraction jobs that's resulted in over
5,000 people being trained and it's been
expand
across the country that's one aspect but
then we also have done research and
looking at where we have a mismatch and
some of our degree programs to where if
some of the need is and speaking now
with educators and higher education
institutions about how we can be working
to make sure that we've got basically
the people that we need to be able to
move these things forward so that's an
advantage a lot of other places in the
region are now I'm sorry across the
country are now trying to emulate well
the work we've been doing here on that
way one of the challenges facing
emerging technologies in the startup
area is is funding how would you
characterize the climate in Pittsburgh
for funding early-stage energy companies
particularly with regards to you know
strategic companies in the area not
necessarily traditional angels and VCs
how would you characterize the the
funding landscape for uh well energy
startups having personally raised money
in Pittsburgh not for energy companies
like to talk a little about that and as
far as you know it's a large user of
energy we are actively an investor in
those sorts of activities and so what
I'd say is is that it's a good place to
be because one of the things I've
noticed about Pittsburgh which is
different than Silicon Valley things
like that is is that there is a really
tight network it's it's pretty easy
within a couple people you can get
connected to most anyone in Pittsburgh
and people are really I've never seen
anything like it we're really actively
wanting to help people out and so you
know we have relationship to all
universities and so people that have
touches to the rates to the universities
can touch us you know there's numbers of
startups that are energy related that we
have conversations with right now so how
does givest row do that crowd you do
that on a continuing ongoing basis magic
well a couple things one is is that you
know we try to stay in touch with the
universities there's also through the
different kinds of you know startup
programs like innovation
works the accelerators awful a valpha
gear you know we have relations for
those people a lot of the tech transfer
people within the universities we have
relationships with so is we have an
ongoing conversation about what we're
interested in what we're trying to do
it's a way for them to say hey you know
I have this company may want to talk to
I have this professor and this idea or
here's the startup then also having
perceive in the startup community I get
calls from people I know hey Carell you
know I got to talk to these guys and so
I would say that it's a great place to
get started because there is a lot of a
network that you can tap into that could
also extend beyond just Pittsburgh -
thank you for the iw and Alpha lab f/11
ear plugs appreciate it I think it's
good I would agree but I know and and
speaking for 30-odd energy companies
that that that we've supported and
invested in over the last six or seven
years I think we would all agree that it
could be better there's been a
significant growth and the number of
investments that are made in energy
companies over the last four to five
years some of that was accelerated or
energized by commitment from the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania but there
still is lacking I think here a fuller
connection to the importance of the
value of these energy startups they're
here though and for a variety of reasons
one career you mentioned is that this is
probably the most collaborative
innovation city and region in the world
you're literally are one or two phone
calls away from somebody who may in
another place feel like they have a
competitive relationship with you and
they will they will support you there
are test beds for just about any type of
research that you might need to do or if
you're working on a product validation
or development you don't have to go too
far to find
Kove estro or a corporate partner that
can help you and as Carly mentioned
we've got a national lab a stone's throw
away and so the access that you have to
this a do e national ambition I should
mention so the access to that these
energy startups have to them is an
access that they would not be able to
get anywhere else
I would I would like to add that that
the access the resources in the
collaboration is there but the capital
is it in and technically you know and
just being honest the the venture the
venture ecosystem here or should just
step up and start investing more dollars
in the energy space you know it's heavy
heavy heavy meds I'm here in bio biotech
and I understand ibly so but in order to
really make though I think the region as
strong as we can more dollars needs to
be going towards energy related in
innovative technologies especially
what's coming out of pit and CMU that
that needs to happen and while there are
lots of larger companies like divest row
that are doing sort of the work
themselves to try to be supportive one
thing that Anna and Jeff and I and
others have been looking into is whether
or not there is a need or a value to
have something more structured so
corporate venture capital group's you
know entities sort of that body where
people and different companies buy into
sort of committing dollars and talents
and mentorship and those kinds of
opportunities exists in other regions
and so there could really be an
opportunity here to do something more
organized and formal this next question
should be a lively one this is from the
audience why won't the accd withdraw
support for the ethane cracker facility
when it will double regional carbon
emissions undoing the climate benefits
of current innovations industrial
development is always complicated
is one way to put it as we mentioned
earlier there's been a commitment to
fuel diversity and having a variety of
different resources contribute to our
energy mix and in order to do so the
caveat to that is to do it right to do
it as well as possible to take into
consideration the environmental impacts
and make sure that we're doing
everything we can to offset them so from
the Allegheny conferences role there
we've been a supporter of sustainable
shale development standards there's a
bunch of best practices and leading
thought on how to do this as well as
possible we've encouraged shale and
they've been partners all along in
taking the best-in-class approach to
this project does that mean that there
will be zero impacts no of course there
will be but the research and the
assessment as to how the the other
values the other benefits that this
brings to the region to workers and
residents here as well as to our natural
gas resource that has a lot of methane
in it and right now it is either being
burned off or basically give it away and
that's bad because ethane has a lot of
value it's in so many of the products we
need for medical purposes to space
travel to your shampoo bottle and to
just burn that off and waste it is worse
than trying to do something with it well
and so that's been that's been the
position that there's there's a real
value to the region in in pursuing this
opportunity but that it needs to be done
in a responsible way all right next
question
what is being done or can be done to
train involve more minorities in the
energy sector and in the energy
entrepreneurship arena not enough
not enough I'm encouraged in a in a few
places we've got an opportunity here in
Pittsburgh if you were here yesterday
you heard about some some concepts from
microgrids in in urban settings there is
some intention to ensure that those
microgrids ultimately are designed and
somewhat supported by those communities
it's a small thing but I I'm hoping that
that becomes a much larger thing part of
this is obviously a workforce
development challenge just across the
board part of this is an educational
issue across the board I'd like to say
that that we've got a Pittsburgh has a
fairly high energy IQ but we still are
not necessarily where we should be I
think actually the first question that
we got from from the audience
illustrate that and we do kind of
question the impacts that energy have on
our communities and that is a sign of a
good high energy IQ but we've got to
start earlier we are an innovative
entrepreneurship as a way to communicate
opportunities in this space to younger
and younger audiences so we actually
have programs for high school-age kids
and I think we've got an opportunity
through that to boost the IQ and
hopefully encourage more and more this
is also inclusion an innovation week
here in Pittsburgh and
and if we continue to have other
opportunities like that I think we'll
start to see positive change to
piggyback Jeff I think it's true and I
think it's exposure right you know a
personal story I didn't know anything
about energy tell us about 25 or 26 it's
just because in my neighborhood in the
way I grew up you know we just said no I
don't know what a kilowatt hour was so
if I'm an elementary school or middle
school or high school and I don't know
what that means
then why would I want to pursue energy
or technology or job or career that way
and it just it just makes sense that if
young people know and understand and you
can have some exposure early on to the
careers or job opportunities that exist
or and they can find their own journey
find their own way and I think there's
enough there's a lot of advocacy groups
and champions and Pittsburgh that are
doing some work I just think you know we
need to do more of it and more
collaboration more consistently and you
will see the results we'll see the fruit
fruits of that but I think we are
scratching the surface of doing that it
just needs more more impact you know and
I know that there's there's a lot going
on here you know I you know Anna was was
gracious enough to allow some of our
students from the walala foundation to
be on CMU's campus to really feel the
impact of entrepreneurship
startups and what it means to attain
that right because somebody still just
don't know so that was that was a
beautiful thing and those are just
that's just that's just the beginning of
it you know and that's I think that's
what we have to go we have to start
somewhere and keep keep that track I'm
glad you mentioned inclusive innovation
week because we're kind of overlapping
events this week one of the
organizations I'm involved with up in
Hermitage has an entrepreneurship
Academy where we bring in high school
seniors from 12 local high schools four
days a week their senior year and the
mornings that go to their anchor school
and the afternoons they come to our
entrepreneurship Academy and the kids
are given a myers-briggs personality
assess
they're put together in teams of three
to four kids you have to come up with a
project by the end of their senior year
and build a working prototype so there's
a lot of Technology and more importantly
it's teaching kids innovation and in
Hermitage which is a rural community
about an hour north of Pittsburgh I'm
very excited to see the diversity in our
our entrepreneurship Academy we're about
40 45 percent girls there's a lot of
minorities in the in the group as well
and the kids kids really doing well
we're looking at bringing that program
to Pittsburgh were actually in
conversations with CMU in terms of
providing a area so the answer to that
question that I think we all here know
that the best performing teams are
diverse teams okay how can students and
young professionals without highly
technical backgrounds support energy
innovation and entrepreneurship and
Pittsburgh region supported or get
involved with it this says support well
I think that you don't miss a have to
have a technical degree D to get
involved with technical type businesses
because you know there's a lot of common
sense that goes into it also I think
there's an education piece that the
magic of the Internet there are so much
information out there that you can you
can fairly quickly become literate in a
lot of different areas and if you look
at a number of stuff entrepreneur
startups they're not going to say
technically they have technical people
work for them or work with them to solve
the problem but they may have a vision
based on looking at things and exploring
different kinds of ideas and then they
find the right technical people to help
make that reality come true so I don't
think you have to be a deeply technical
person involved at all both blue tree
and innovation works invest in in teams
and every team has technical wizards
that are good at the science part of it
but they also have to have
components can you speak to that a
little bit Jeff in terms of what
constitutes a well-balanced team and if
if you're not a technical wizard you
know you might be able to get really
good at marketing or finance or
something else if you could speak you've
got to be well balanced as a team and
what we continue to see is that while
there may be technical founding teams
that the the best performing ones are
the ones that recognize that despite
their expertise and electrical
engineering or material science that
alone isn't necessarily going to move
their idea and company forward they need
other skill sets
most of the energy companies that that I
work with have a very broad array of
talent on the team not all of the team
members have college degrees many of the
key members of those teams have
transferable experience so in the in the
energy space going back to some of the
kind of workforce related subjects from
before it's very easy to transfer
experience from perhaps one fossil
technology to another whether it's a
fluid system most you know most heating
is still at least in my day and the Navy
didn't matter whether or not it was
nuclear energy or it was liquid fuel
that energy was used to make water
really hot turn it into steam and then
you know turn turn the propeller at the
back of the ship I mean that was
basically a simplified but so there
there are a lot of transferable skills I
think we need to do a better job of
helping a lot of those individuals
realize that those skills that they have
already acquired are transferable and it
and that's part of that energy IQ piece
that I think is missing why is no one
mentioned climate change this is from a
student maybe one of your students will
why is no one mentioned climate change
is a driver for innovation and
creativity I'm glad you did whoever you
are because it is right we we respond to
problems and you know issues in the
world that's where creativity comes from
and so the move to figuring out other
forms of energy production and
alternative fuels and how we're going to
store it and get it to where it's needed
and all those things is is certainly
heightens by the fact that people
proceeds that there's a real need to to
figure out alternatives
I believe in climate change so I believe
in a all the above approach to energy
because in part because of that I think
and this goes beyond our administration
we have not been thinking forward enough
over all that's not a indictment on
Pittsburgh I think it's just an
indictment on our kind of national kind
of energy desires we continue to I think
missed the boat at least a little bit
when it comes to thinking about what the
energy technology is going to be for our
future but you know some of the best
work that is actually being done is
being done here and that's another thing
to be encouraged about I do think that
across the board though we are very
sensitive to you know the impacts that
even the older technologies have on you
know on our communities and
we'll continue to try to get better at
that - I think climate change is really
really really big right and sometimes I
think it's so big that people forget you
know that we can take steps in solving
the problem you know I listen to a roar
sure are say that you know we've been
we've been discussing the building
emissions or 40% fertile has twenty
years and then I heard Donna Andersen
say that he hates to work Harvard so you
have these competing interests as well
as what you know what what makes dollars
and cents you know is it is it is it uh
is it a more cultural aspect that we
attack climate change or you know how do
we really truly make the make the
business case and the cultural case
that's why we need it I think if we can
really marry the two together and not
have big big private equity firms like
kill it and we have great nonprofit
organizations like GPA championing and
marry the two we can solve that I think
you can you have a good chance of
solving the climate the climate climate
change but hemad if you will you know
it's so big you know and that but it's
it's trying to find a happy medium of
what what makes the most sense there
really is that two parts right there's
the production side you know coming
where is carbon coming from and how can
we reduce that but then also on the end
user side right reducing our energy
usage increasing energy efficiency and
again we've got a lot of the leading
research and ideas and technology for
those things with or it's building
systems or transportation or others
happening here in Pittsburgh and so the
one thing we could always use more of is
probably more research dollars and that
to build off what Jeff was saying that's
one thing where as I as a country we we
still actually are not even close to
investing enough in Rd if we wanted to
actually make it difference to some of
these goals we should be putting more
dollars towards it
the comment new technologies to existing
applications is important new
technologies to existing applications
are you able to speak to new
technologies being considered by the
panelists well we do we look at new to
new technologies across a couple of
fronts one is sources of energy serve
example renewables so we're looking at
wind power we're looking at solar we're
also looking at the other part of the
equation which is consumption and so
we've invested a ton of money in making
our processes more efficient so you know
we've we've come up with new ways one of
the big things we make is chlorine and
it takes a massive amount of electricity
in that and so we spent you know huge
dollars come up with technology that can
reduce that energy usage by 25 percent
so I don't think kind of a will and Jeff
we're talking about is there's not one
size fits all in terms of solving that
energy equation there's renewable
production but also to there's more
effective and efficient use of it and I
think that you can get further down the
path in terms of a sustainable future by
attacking the problem of how
inefficiently we use energy as well we
we've invested in companies excuse me
that have platform technologies that
touch a number of energy applications
whether it's utilizing specialized
polymers to reduce the amount of water
that it takes to go down a fracking rig
reduces the amount of flow back water
that comes back up so that's you know
addressing something that's really clear
but really we don't you know we don't do
their own horns about technology like
that could be material science that
helps coat the heat exchangers and power
plants with a with a material and a
technology that is not detrimental
impacting the
environment in the process we've got a
company called
like watt learn which is making you know
a duty a single duty cycle battery that
really does not have a brain smart so
these are technologies that are being
applied to existing processes today and
then here in Pittsburgh we also have a
number of energy efficiency technologies
that are being strapped on to smart
meters that are looking at comprehensive
ways of reducing demand today not a
generation from now and making
significant impacts in our carbon
footprint and I would add that within
400 miles of the let's call it Allegheny
County
there's 17,000 manufacturing and
industrial plants chemicals plastics
manufacturing and fabrication place and
all those plants so should profit from
the petrochemical and ethane production
but we're not talking about the current
innovation and technologies that could
make those companies more efficient
because a lot of more small small
companies and small businesses you know
or you know less than a hundred million
dollars in revenue in in a tremendous to
statistic that that we've looked at is
you know big big huge manufacturing
companies have found a way to latch on
technology to make their processes more
efficient companies that make less than
100 million dollars don't and it's like
80 percent of those companies don't so
you see this huge gap in revenue and in
production because they don't they don't
latch on innovative technologies so
that's a huge opportunity for you know
new innovation and technology companies
within this region to go and seek out
those those businesses in those come
he's uh that that jetta spoke of and
that korea spoke Oh huge opportunity Ben
would like to know your opinions on the
on the carbon tax my personal opinion is
that it's the most efficient way to
create a market that would help us have
the money to actually be able to invest
in the options that can reduce our use
of carbon so you put a price on it that
means the market can respond without a
price it means that you're sort of
hitting some companies businesses
technologies options against each other
instead of actually creating a a level
and predictable way forum for folks to
engage
after hearing dawn from Blackstone last
night at the dawn who's on stage and by
the way your sock game is strong very
strong today it really it is I'm
starting to change my thinking a little
bit on on that on that on the carbon
question what I would have said and I'm
about to say is that the US is lagging
behind again it's the energy IQ question
lagging behind perhaps in most of the EU
children for the most part have a much
better sense there where their power
comes from they know roughly where the
plant is that's probably keeping the
lights on and here I don't always know
where my energy is coming from and so if
we can't get up to some you know minimum
knowledge level about all of those
impacts it's really hard to to get
behind or to get the nation behind
factoring in all of the other things
that we should be factoring in that are
very important to to create that type of
system so you know I think that it's
going to happen but I think it's going
to continue to take a while before we
get
Jeff could you explain to the audience
what EU is for the energy IQ well I just
meant and I just met the European Union
in that case and not energy you see yeah
too many acronyms yeah yeah that's right
okay Jeff and I also wear other hats
were both on the board of the Green
Building Alliance and we had Paul Hawken
come to Pittsburgh a couple months ago
he gave a talk about a book he is
editing and it's called drawdown and
anyone interested in climate change it's
a great book he didn't write it but he
talked to a hundred of the smartest
people in the world who identified had
been working on climate change issues
for years and he identified a hundred
small things that we can do to really
reverse climate change so I highly
recommend that to anybody who's
interested this next question is from
Ben how how our nearby University is
collaborating on energy innovation
research startups what are your opinions
on how this can be improved so a lot of
the companies that end up coming to
innovation works are going into our
accelerators are coming out of the
universities here it's Byrd other
universities around the country and I
think that the universities that embrace
innovation and give students who've got
great ideas the space to to grow those
ideas is a great thing so we really
benefit my group from from those
universities that are supporting it
there's a woman there's more than a
billion dollars a year now coming into
the region in federal research dollars
and the startup community ends up
becoming a kind of secondary beneficiary
and so they're able to leverage that
once they start their companies but I
think that we can always there's always
room to strengthen the connections
throughout the ecosystem so we could be
doing more with some of the larger
companies that are in the region we
could be doing more we being the startup
community of connecting and maybe even
deeper into the universities figuring
out how we can move faster this next
question goes back to the fossil fuel
industry
what's the Holy Grail you see in oil and
gas technology referring to what would
be the ideal disruptor to the industry
well I think it depends because from
from a petrochemical standpoint it's
really looking at it going from those
fossil fuels to bio-based and that's a
huge challenge if that's if it you know
making that a reality would would would
be a huge step forward in this this
whole sustainability aspect of of
production of all the plastics and
polymers that we use on a day to day
basis so that would be enormous for an
energy standpoint it states the
renewables basically you're not going to
use fossil fuels anymore I mean I think
we we know that at least from a
transportation fuel standpoint we are
not going to be as dependent on fossil
fuels as we have been now there's going
to be a shift in in other areas as well
but I think it's I think it's clear that
evey will be the predominant
transportation technology within our
lifetimes for most applications and so I
think that is driving unintended you
know driving us away from the dependency
at least in some areas of the energy
sector on
and where I've said it really seems like
energy storage technology is what's
holding us back in a lot of ways for all
kinds of applications if you can right
now a lot of our energy is just in time
delivery right that's what we need we
need it when you flip on the light
switch that has to be basically produced
it said to you and if you can get to the
point where you can store the energy
that's being produced at times when
people are using it the entire equation
for how we have to balance our electric
grid in particular could really really
change and that would be the tipping
point all right I think I'm getting the
hook here so I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank our panel
kuri Crookston from Co vestro will Allen
from nascent group Jeff McDaniel from
innovation work Carlie Dobbins Buckwald
from Allegheny Conference if we could
please give them a big hand
and Anna who's up next so first let's
take a minute and thank our panel this
morning thank you so much panel
[Applause]